When we started living together, we started to grow up. The reason
why things turned out like this is that
my wife is a wild
girl. I wonder if all girls are like this. She
fixes her hair every day and goes to bed, but it's all undone in no time.
[Music]
Oh
And maybe because my body temperature is high, I often drink ounces in the middle of the night.When I drink
water, I get so high that I'm half asleep and often steal my futon from me.But I'm not
publishing
anymore.  Is it okay to dye it?
Even if I try, if it happens after I burn it and dye it,
then what's the problem even if everything happens? Because Tsukasa-chan is
my wife.
It's expensive, and it
smells so good, it makes my brain blink No, it
smells so big and good, and
Oh no, this is the one that's going to get caught!
Something about this pops
[Music]
Open
Hmph.